[Music]
what happened we'll tell her what's up
Mary job better Foucault will tell her
story and unscripted documentary who's
sending this down the line let me see
Deadline Hollywood Deadline Hollywood
hold the press Mary Jo Buttafuoco will
tell her story who do you guys even know
who Mary Jo Buttafuoco is know does
anybody know who she is over there
you shouldn't no no I'm asking the
enterance I'm not at the cruise I dated
her okay to the prom
that was my first wife no but that's the
story from week 1982 words no no I think
we I think it was we were making fun of
that that's crazy that you shouldn't no
that's that's not you should please
don't look it up it's a horrible thing
from the Knighton but it was a cartoon
show on Long Island I've heard about
what happened he yes a mansion with a
lien guy that who had a body shop that
was having an affair with a what was she
70 well this was first of all we can
it's all Jerry lovino it's Jerry it was
Jerry before he changed his name to
Jerry Vivino remember Jerry when you
were but a Foucault had a body shop got
a body shop remember on Long Island oh
yeah and you were with the young girl
and then she got mad is she the one that
shot yes yeah she came she came to
confront his wife in the outside the
house
yeah and shot her in the face with like
a 22 yeah
and then she had kind of a paralyzed
face right yes and but a foucault was
around being away and what are you gonna
do but a being but a boo right and then
what happened irresistible
I own a body shop
[Music]
you